On joue la dernière minute de la prolongation du quart de finale de la coupe du monde de 2010 c'est la 120ème minute le score est encore de 1 partout entre le Ghana et l'Uruguay
Ce coup franc excentré est surement le coup franc de la dernière chance avant la séance de tir au but
C'est bien tiré ! Oh c'est dangereux ! Oh le sauvetage de Suarez avec le pied, et encore... mais c'est une main non ?
Stupeur dans le stade ! L'arbitre n'hésite pas une seule seconde : Carton rouge pour Suarez et penalty pour le Ghana
Asamoah Gyan s'apprête à envoyer le dernier pays africain de la compétition en demi-finale de la coupe du monde,
un stade de la compétition qu'aucune équipe africaine n'a su atteindre par le passé
Asamoah Gyan s'élance
Oh c'est la barre !
La barre, la barre, la barre...
L'arbitre siffle la fin du match
Ghana et Uruguay sont encore à égalité, la qualification pour la demi-finale se jouera donc dans une séance de tir au but
et le Ghana finira par la perdre
Le lendemain, les journaux européens crient au scandale.
Suarez incarne le diable
C'est un voyou sans respect
Mais en Uruguay, Suarez devient un héros national. C'est le soldat qui n'a pas hésité à se sacrifier pour la gloire de son pays
Alors Suarez : Ange ou démon ?
Eh bien au final, il s'agit avant tout d'un cas où un joueur n'a fait que suivre ses incentives.
Suarez a fait ce qui était bien pour lui et selon lui.
Et d'ailleurs, il n'était pas le seul à vouloir faire ce qu'il a fait.
Cette remarque est le fondement de la théorie des jeux, c'est la branche des mathématiques qui s'intéresse aux interactions entre individus et institutions
Dans cette théorie, chacun fait ce qui est bien pour lui et selon lui
Alors avant que vous ne criiez au scandale et ne pensiez qu'il s'agit là d'une offense à la nature humaine
Je précise que ce qui est bien pour quelqu'un selon quelqu'un
peut parfaitement être altruiste.
D'ailleurs Suarez n'a pas fait ce qui était bien pour "lui, lui"
Ce qui était bien pour lui selon lui était quelque chose de relativement altruiste
puisqu'il préférait se faire expulser et voir les siens gagner
Plus généralement, les patriotes sont ceux qui pensent que ce qui est bien pour eux selon eux
est le triomphe de leur nation ou de leurs groupes sociaux, peu importe leur sort individuel.
Quand je dis que chacun fait ce qui est bien pour lui et selon lui,
toutes les valeurs éthiques et morales de la personne en question mais aussi ses croyances sur le monde qui l'entoure
sont contenues dans le "pour lui et selon lui".
Et d'une façon cruciale, comme nos valeurs morales divergent d'une personne à l'autre,
ce qui est bien selon et pour un libertarien
ne sera pas la même chose que ce qui est bien pour et selon un marxiste.
En fait quand on se demande si quelque chose est bien ou mal
ça doit être un réflexe de théoricien des jeux que de se demander :
"Bien pour et selon qui ?"
Alors en général pour une personne donnée c'est difficile de savoir ce qui est bien
pour et selon elle
Quoique dans notre société il semble y avoir une préférence très récurrente
qui explique une grosse partie de l'économie et du monde du travail
En effet, il semble que la plupart des employés, qu'ils soient techniciens, managers, PDG ou politiciens
ne veulent pas perdre leur job
Et si possible
ils préféreraient monter dans la hiérarchie.
Du coup les agissements des techniciens, managers, PDG ou politiciens
seront inéluctablement les conséquences de leur désir de rester à leur poste
et de monter dans la hiérarchie
et des incentives qui leur seront donnés pour ce faire.
Ainsi, il est devenu extrêmement courant de pointer du doigt
les politiciens, les publicitaires et les médias comme étant la cause de tous les maux qui frappent nos sociétés
Si seulement ces individus arrêtaient la pédagogie, le putaclic et les fake news !
Si seulement ils faisaient preuve de pédagogie et d'impartialité !
Si seulement ces individus se comportaient de manière éthique, se dit-on,
on pourrait enfin vivre dans une société rationnelle et optimisée
qui ne chercherait pas à désinformer le peuple,
stigmatiser ses minorités
et créer des besoins infondés.
Mais pour le théoricien des jeux, ce wishful thinking est un vœu pieu.
Non pas parce qu'il est dans la nature humaine de céder à des tentations démoniaques
mais parce que dans ces milieux,
les incentives sont ce qu'ils sont.
Tout individu de ces milieux qui dévie des stratégies classiques
et qui cherche à se comporter comme le plus grand des saints qui soient
sera un politicien sans supporters,
un publicitaire sans clients
et un média sans lecteurs.
Il ne sera plus que poussière.
Dans ces milieux,
ne survivront que ceux qui auront joué le jeu
et tant que le jeu n'aura pas changé
les actions des politiciens, publicitaires et médias
ne changeront pas non plus.
Haïssez le jeu. Pas les joueurs
Je ne dis pas qu'il ne sert à rien de promouvoir l'éthique et la morale
et d'ailleurs je trouves que les vidéos de Youtube culturelles le font très bien.
Après tout il arrive que l'opinion du grand public
conduise au licenciement de certains dirigeants.
Mais il ne faut pas perdre de vue que plus le processus d'élimination des joueurs non performants est intense,
plus les joueurs qui seront encore en jeu sont ceux qui répondent
aux incentives.
Plus il y a de compétition,
plus les techniciens, managers, PDG ou politiciens qu'il restera
seront ceux qui sont gouvernés par les incentives qui leur sont donnés
Et ce principe explique pourquoi certains dirigeants fraudent,
et pourquoi d'autres ne fraudent pas.
Comme leurs employés, ce que les dirigeants désirent avant tout c'est ne pas subir l'humiliation du licenciement
sans doute parce que nos crétins de cerveaux
exagèrent davantage les pertes qu'ils ne célèbrent les gains.
Or, effectuer une fraude alors que tout va bien
augmente la probabilité de licenciement.
En revanche,
quand les résultats de l'entreprise compromettent grandement leur avenir dans l'entreprise,
les dirigeants auront un grand incentive
à frauder pour garder leur emploi.
Autrement dit, la théorie des jeux combinée à la psychologie expérimentale
prédit que c'est en période de crise
que les comportements immoraux sont les plus probables.
Et cette prédiction théorique a été confirmée empiriquement,
notamment par des analyses de Bruce Bueno De Mesquita
qui a pu observer que c'est précisément lorsque les bénéfices des entreprises sont au plus faible
que les fraudes des dirigeants sont les plus fréquentes.
Haïssez le jeu. Pas les joueurs.
Si les techniciens, managers, PDG ou politiciens font des choses que l'on juge moralement mauvaises,
ce n'est donc pas que vis-à-vis d'eux qu'il faut sévir.
c'est surtout le jeu qu'ils jouent qu'il faut questionner.
Or il me semble que trop souvent
on critique les joueurs
et on oublie le jeu.
C'est le cas par exemple quand on identifie le capitalisme et l'économie de marché
aux grands patrons du CAC 40.
En particulier il me semble que bien souvent on se focalise sur les grands gagnants du jeu
et on en vient à oublier quelques propriétés fondamentales du jeu
comme le fait que la plupart des jeux en économie
ne sont pas à somme nulle.
Autrement dit, en général ce qu'un joueur gagne
n'est pas ce qu'un autre perd, surtout en économie
Si M.Lambda achète un rouleau de PQ à 5€ à la station service,
c'est parce qu'au moment de l'achat
le rouleau de PQ a plus de valeur à ses yeux
que ces 5€.
Alors bien sûr on a quand même envie de dire que M. Lambda s'est fait avoir d'une certaine manière,
mais si l'on pense cela
c'est sans doute à cause de l'effet d'ancrage dont Science Etonnante vous a parlé dans sa série "Crétin de cerveau".
On a tellement pris l'habitude de payer beaucoup moins pour du PQ
que l'on pense se faire avoir et y perdre à faire la transaction.
On a alors envie de haïr le vendeur et l'entreprise qui nous ont vendu le PQ
et on va s'empresser de s'en plaindre auprès de nos amis.
Cependant, si l'échange commercial a bien eu lieu
c'est bien parce que M. Lambda et la station
y ont tous 2 gagné au change.
Analysez le jeu. Pas les joueurs.
On reviendra plus longuement sur l'économie des marchés, ses bienfaits et ses défaillances
ainsi que sur la négociation mathématique des prix
plus tard dans cette série sur la démocratie.
Pour l'heure, et étant donnée l'actualité, j'aimerais que l'on applique l'analyse des jeux
à la politique.
Selon la théorie des jeux, la question qu'il faudrait nous poser n'est pas si chaque candidat est bon ou mauvais,
la question qui importe c'est quels sont les incentives que notre système démocratique impose
aux hommes politiques d'aujourd'hui.
Tout d'abord il faut bien voir que, surtout à l'approche des élections,
les hommes politiques ont avant tout intérêt à dire ce que les citoyens veulent entendre.
Ils ont avant tout intérêt
à suivre l'opinion publique
et c'est en cela que le système représentatif est, au moins en partie,
démocratique.
Je vous invite à garder ça en tête lorsque les politiciens disent ou font des trucs qui vous déplaisent
Trop souvent quand un politicien défend une idée démocratique qui nous déplaît,
on a tendance à critiquer le politicien ou à lui reprocher son populisme
ou sa démagogie
alors qu'il ne fait que dire ou faire ce que le peuple veut.
Cependant pour acquérir l'adhésion d'une majorité du peuple,
dire ce qu'il veut entendre ne suffit pas
Dans l'épisode 2 on a vu en particulier que, étant donnés les scrutins que l'on utilise aujourd'hui,
pourvu que 2 grands partis dominent le paysage politique,
les politiciens ont tout intérêt à se ranger dans le parti qui leur correspond le plus
plutôt qu'à proposer des idées ou des combinaisons d'idées qui sortiraient de la norme.
Qui plus est, ils ont intérêt à constamment se plaindre des partis déjà au pouvoir
à répéter que le pays va mal
et à prétendre qu'ils sont la seule alternative à la médiocrité ambiante.
Mieux encore, s'ils pensent n'avoir aucune chance d'acquérir le pouvoir,
et c'est le cas de la grande majorité des candidats de notre scrutin à 2 tours
pour rester à la tête de leur parti politique et gagner en influence
les politiciens ont même intérêt à attirer l'attention médiatique
en proposant des mesures radicales
et en faisant des promesses irréalistes
puisque, n'étant pas élus,
ils n'auront de toutes façons pas à tenir leurs promesses
Et puis dans l'épisode 7,
on a vu que les politiciens ont tout intérêt à concevoir leurs idées telles des virus.
Ils ont intérêt à soutenir des idées faciles à propager
à les rendre suffisamment flexibles pour être réinterprétées par leurs hôtes
et à les mêler à la fascination, à l'angoisse, à la moquerie et à la colère.
Il semble même dans leur intérêt
d'aborder des sujets sensibles avec des positions marquées
de sorte à se créer un groupe de fans inconditionnels
mais aussi de sorte à se créer une opposition
et à alors envahir le paysage médiatique
avec un sujet qui divise
Pire encore : Comme on l'a vu dans l'épisode 6,
les électeurs s'isolent de plus en plus dans des filter bubbles
dont ils ne reçoivent qu'une information très biaisée.
C'est ainsi qu'il pourrait même être préférable pour les politiciens de dire une chose et son contraire,
de sorte que chaque filter bubble puisse
cherry picker ce que le politicien dit de mieux
voire adapter le cherry picking
aux différentes communautés du Web
Pour faire un gros score au premier tour,
et sachant que nos crétins de cerveaux aiment et croient vrai ce qui leur est familier
de nos jours plus que jamais
les politiciens doivent faire le buzz.
Pour un politicien le pire n'est pas de se faire des ennemis,
de s'auto-contredire ou de dire des bêtises,
le pire est d'être ignoré.
Encore une fois je ne suis pas là en train de faire le procès des politiciens.
Les joueurs vont et viennent.
Ce que j'essaie modestement de prédire là,
ce sont les conséquences du jeu politique tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
et je suis sûr que ma lecture du jeu politique est très incomplète
et que vous allez vous empresser de le souligner dans les commentaires
J'espère tout de même vous avoir donné un aperçu de la perspective d'un théoricien des jeux
qui est, je pense, une perspective assez souvent déficiente.
Pensez y : Haïssez le jeu. Pas les joueurs.
La dernière fois on a parlé du principe fondamental de la politique selon Bruce Bueno De Mesquita
et il y en a beaucoup parmi vous qui ont fait le lien avec la théorie de Machiavel.
Donc très rapidement Machiavel était en gros le premier théoricien de la politique
à penser la politique de manière assez pragmatique et en considérant que les hommes ne sont pas des êtres
bienveillants, qui vont toujours faire ce qui est bien pour tout le monde
et que en pratique,
la politique c'est une lutte de pouvoir
et que du coup pour être prince et pour avoir une certaine stabilité dans son royaume,
il fallait ne pas hésiter à être cruel par moments
C'est d'ailleurs Mesquita dans son bouquin "The Dicator's Handbook"
mais aussi dans le bouquin "The Logic of Political Survival"
il fait un peu l'éloge de Machiavel à plusieurs reprises
Si vous voulez en savoir plus sur Machiavel je vous recommande la super vidéo de Politikon
ainsi que la vidéo de Cyrus North.
Raphaël, Pierre et d'autres parmi vous dans les commentaires m'ont demandé
sur quoi je reposais pour dire que les prédictions de Mesquita étaient plus justes que les avis des experts,
alors tout d'abord Mesquita l'affirme lui-même,
mais aussi apparemment un rapport de la NSA qui semble prétendre
qu'en effet les prédictions de Mesquita sont plus justes que les avis des experts
Alors malheureusement je n'ai jamais réussi à mettre la main sur ce document et si vous le trouvez n'hésitez pas
à me l'envoyer
Je vous recommande notamment la conférence TED que Bruce Bueno De Mesquita a donnée
au sujet d'une prédiction sur l'Iran et le nucléaire.
Et dans son bouquin "Prectiction : How to see and shape the future with game theory"
il y a énormément de prédictions que Mesquita raconte qu'il a faites dans le passé.
Alors il y aurait beaucoup beaucoup à dire, il y a énormément d'exemples dans ce bouquin que je vous recommande encore une fois très vivement
mais par exemple dans ce bouquin Mesquita raconte la première prédiction d'un de ses modèles
en 1979 pour l'élection du premier ministre en Inde
En gros il y avant 2 grands candidats, et Mesquita pensait que l'un des 2 grands candidats était favori,
comme pas mal d'observateurs de l'époque
et en fait son modèle a prédit l'élection  d'un tout autre candidat, un outsider que personne n'a vu venir,
Et Mesquita raconte qu'à ce moment il croyait quand même que la logique de son modèle était super fiable
du coup il a quand même publié sa prédiction
et quelques mois plus tard il se trouve que son algorithme avait raison
et que c'est cet outsider qui a été élu premier ministre en Inde
Plus généralement ça fait 30 ou 40 ans que Mesquita fait ce genre de prédictions,
qu'il a un énorme Track Record et surtout il a monté une entreprise qui vend des prédictions
et son entreprise a l'air de très bien se porter.
Qu'un mec qui a une entreprise qui fait fortune en ne vendant que des prédictions fondées sur son algorithme
ben c'est que l'algorithme marche j'ai envie de dire.
Et pour ceux qui douteraient encore malgré tout de l'honnêteté intellectuelle de Mesquita,
et notamment de la manière dont il raconte ses prédictions dans ce livre,
on peut rajouter le fait qu'il est professeur académique,
il a publié des trucs qui sont peer reviewed donc qui ont été relus par des pairs
Et le bouquin "The logic of political survival" a été coécrit avec 3 autres auteurs et publié à MIT press
bref ça ressemble quand même pas mal à un dossier ultra solide
qu'est le dossier de Bruce Bueno De Mesquita
Tony Pellerin et Milk2048 demandent comment aligner les incentives pour que les incentives
des hommes politiques soient les bons
Alors les "bons" incentives ce n'est pas clair ce que ça veut dire : Bons pour qui ?
Mais plus généralement le principe de la démocratie représentative
c'est justement ça, c'est d'essayer d'aligner les incentives des politiciens avec la volonté du peuple.
Et donc contrairement à ce que je vois beaucoup écrit,
le principe de la démocratie représentative
n'est absolument pas le fait que le pays doit être gouverné
par un ensemble de personnes qui est représentatif du peuple
Ce qui est censé être démocratique en démocratie représentative,
c'est surtout le fait que nos représentants
ont des incentives qui sont alignés avec la volonté du peuple
à savoir pour être et rester au pouvoir
les politiciens ont quand même pas mal tendance à devoir faire ce que le peuple veut qu'ils fassent.
Alors bien sûr ce n'est pas tout à fait le cas, notamment parce qu'il y a des lobbys, parce qu'il y a des gens qui ont
d'une certaine manière plus de parole que d'autres,
des gens qui par exemple manifestent et du coup font plus peser leurs voix
que celles de ceux qui ne manifestent pas typiquement.
Je ne suis pas en train de défendre la démocratie représentative en disant que c'est bien ou que c'est mal,
que c'est archi-démocratique ou pas
ce que je suis en train de dire c'est que l'argument selon lequel
la démocratie représentative n'est pas démocratique
parce que les représentants ne sont pas représentatifs
C'est un argument qui n'est pas tout à fait celui de ceux qui voudraient défendre la démocratie représentative
victor levy nous demande pourquoi Obama n'a pas essayé de rester au pouvoir par la force en faisant un coup d'état ou je sais pas trop quoi
Il faut voir qu'il y a plusieurs niveaux de pouvoir.
Bien sûr il y a le grand pouvoir qui est un peu le président
qui est celui dont on pense aujourd'hui qu'il a le plus de pouvoir dans beaucoup de démocraties,
cependant il y a aussi les dirigeants des partis,
il y a juste être une personne d'influence dans un parti
avoir un poste de sénateur etc, il y a énormément de degrés de pouvoir
et un ancien président a encore beaucoup d'influence une fois qu'il n'est plus président
s'il tente maintenant un coup d'état il risque de tout perdre
Si jamais Obama tentait de prendre le pouvoir par la force,
sans doute qu'il n'y arriverait pas, en tout cas le risque d'échec serait très très très très élevé
c'est pour ça qu'Obama n'a sans doute pas cherché à garder le pouvoir par la force
De la même manière, Serge, Denis et [****] pensent que le fait que Hollande ne se soit pas représenté pour la présidentielle de 2017
est un signe que la théorie de Mesquita est fausse
non, pas du tout
Les sondages semblent indiquer que Hollande a en ce moment un record d'impopularité pour un ancien président
donc il a surement fait les calculs
il s'est dit que s'il essayait de se représenter pour la présidentielle de 2017
alors il risquait un échec cuisant qui lui ferait perdre
de l'influence auprès de son parti
et du coup il a préféré partir dans la dignité
en espérant sans doute que plus tard la roue tournerait à nouveau
et que il se retrouverait peut être dans 5 ans ou je sais pas trop quoi
à nouveau dans des situations où il pourrait prétendre
à beaucoup de pouvoir.
Quant à dire que Hollande n'a rien fait pour rester au pouvoir une fois qu'il a été élu,
je ne pense pas que ce soit vrai, c'est juste que le jeu de la politique
est un jeu très difficile, très compliqué.
Il faut satisfaire à la fois les électeurs et les lobbys
et puis il a sans doute été victime d'un contexte socio-économico-culturel
avec notamment les attaques terroristes
peut être que si la France avait gagné l'Euro 2016 ça aurait été différent.
Antoine et Tony m'ont poussé à aller un petit peu plus loin dans la description du modèle de Mesquita.
Un point important du modèle de Mesquita
c'est que en fait il y a plusieurs degrés de pouvoir
et du coup les politiciens sont plus ou moins
prêts à accepter des concessions sur leur route au pouvoir.
Donc il est possible que pour un politicien par exemple, être président sur une échelle de 0 à 100 ça corresponde à 100
peut être que être président d'un parti c'est 80 pour certains
ça peut être 90 pour d'autres, ça peut être 20 pour d'autres
donc il y a des différences aussi entre les candidats
dans les différents niveaux successifs de pouvoir et il faut prendre tout ça en compte
pour pouvoir faire des modèles.
Et ensuite, une fois que l'on a ça,
il faut imaginer qu'à chaque instant,
chaque politicien va essayer de convertir d'autres gens vers eux
donc ils vont essayer d'influencer les gens, avec différents niveaux de charisme à chaque fois
et typiquement ils vont cibler certaines stratégies, ou essayer de convaincre certaines personnes d'une certaine manière
pour maximiser ce qu'on appelle l'espérance d'utilité
c'est à dire qu'ils vont essayer de voir selon leurs croyances et ce qu'ils sont capables de faire
et selon les stratégies que les autres personnes vont adopter à chaque instant
is vont essayer de maximiser le score moyen qu'ils auraient selon leurs croyances.
Alors quand je dis le mot croyance là c'est la même chose qu'un modèle probabiliste qu'ils auraient en tête
en fait c'est un modèle bayésien pour ceux qui connaissent
dont l'aléatoire vient aussi du fait que les autres individus
ont leurs propres préférences qu'on ne connait pas forcément exactement,
donc il peut y avoir des problèmes d'informations incomplètes
et il peut aussi y avoir de l'incertitude
qui vient du fait que les autres joueurs peuvent jouer des stratégies mixtes
c'est à dire aléatoires.
On reviendra plus longuement sur certains concepts importants de la théorie des jeux
notamment l'utilité, l'utilité espérée, toutes ces notions de stratégie,
voire l'information incomplète plus tard dans cette série sur la démocratie
mais malheureusement je m'en excuse je n'ai pas prévu de rentrer plus en détail dans les théories de Mesquita
pour plusieurs raisons, notamment le fait qu'il n'y a pas "une" théorie de Mesquita.
C'est en tout cas l'impression que j'ai eue en lisant ses modèles
qui malheureusement sont confidentiels donc c'est difficile de savoir tout ce qui s'y passe
mais en fait il semblerait que Mesquita réinvente à chaque fois un modèle
qui à chaque fois est assez distant d'un cas à l'autre.
Donc il n'y a pas une théorie de Mesquita
il y a plutôt quelques principes fondamentaux
et à chaque fois une adaptation de ces principes fondamentaux au cas par cas,
à chaque question qu'il cherche à étudier
et qui dépend notamment de ce que disent les experts
donc il y a énormément de données qui sont fournies par les experts,
notamment à quel point tel ou tel candidat est prêt à accepter telle ou telle concession
qui sont en fait vraiment les données les plus importantes dans le jeu politique
donc vous pouvez imaginer que plus les experts donnent beaucoup d'informations très détaillées,
plus il faut modifier le modèle pour prendre tout ça en compte.
Et en particulier au final ça fait des modèles qui sont souvent un petit peu moches
d'un point de vue élegance mathématique
en fait Mesquita semble suggérer que le plus important
ce n'est pas vraiment le modèle en tant que tel,
que les détails du modèle ne vont pas avoir une énorme importance
ce qui va vraiment permettre de progresser par rapport à l'intuition surtout
c'est surtout le fait de poser un modèle qui soit conforme au principe fondamental de la politique
et ensuite à lancer ce modèle et à voir quelles en sont les conséquences.
Bart Toutatis nous demande quelles sont les limites du modèle de Mesquita.
Alors bien sur vous imaginez qu'en 30-40 ans de carrière Mesquita a fait quelques prédictions qui n'ont pas été justes.
Dans ce livre il parle de quelques prédictions qu'il a faites qui ne sont pas justes
et il explique pourquoi elles n'ont pas été justes, il explique quelques limites du modèle
notamment il y a un cas qu'il raconte
où notamment un des politiciens qui avait un rôle majeur à jouer dans son modèle
s'est retrouvé au cœur d'un scandale sexuel
qui n'avait rien à voir avec la prédiction de prime abord
donc de façon générale, tout ce qui n'est pas dans le modèle et qui a un effet important
risque de complètement changer les conclusions du modèle
ça c'est le cas pour tout modèle finalement
Après, pour être totalement honnête je suspecte un peu Mesquita d'avoir choisi des fausses prédictions
dans son bouquin qu'il a arrangé un petit peu dans son discours.
Samuel Boudet fait la remarque que juste parce que les prédictions du modèle sont justes
ne veut pas dire que les postulats et les hypothèse du modèle sont forcément vraies
et si vous suivez bien la vidéo précédente je n'ai jamais dit ça,
j'ai bien fait gaffe de ne jamais dire qu'il fallait considérer que les postulats sont vrais ou indiscutables.
Plus généralement,  je crois énormément à la citation de George Box
"Tous les modèles sont faux mais certains sont utiles"
donc il ne faut pas voir les modèles de Mesquita
Comme une description vraie, véritablement vrai et indiscutablement vraie de la réalité
à mon sens la bonne manière d'interpréter les modèles de Mesquita
c'est de voir que ces modèles sont capables de faire de meilleures prédictions
donc si on veut faire des prédictions,
si on veuts'intéresser vraiment à la politique et voir quelles sont les conséquences des politiques
et de l'élection d'untel ou d'untel,
vu que la logique de Mesquita fait mieux que la logque de même les experts de la politique
il est largement préférable à mon sens
d'essayer de croire le modèle de Mesquita et sa logique
plutôt que d'essayer de réfléchir par rapport à sa propre logique
ou à sa propre intuition.
En particulier je n'exclue pas le fait qu'un homme politique en particulier
veuille avant tout faire passer une certaine loi
et que c'est sa vraie fonction objectif
mais de toute façon pour faire passer cette loi
il va lui falloir absolument être et rester au pouvoir
et du coup son comportement pour en arriver au moment où il adopte cette loi
sera indiscernable du comportement d'un homme politique qui veut juste
être et rester au pouvoir
Bref, les hypothèses du modèle de Mesquita ne sont pas forcément vraies vraies vraies
mais ils sont surement beaucoup plus utiles à utiliser
pour faire des prédictions notamment en politique
que toutes les intuitions, toutes les idées que l'on pourrait avoir
et en particulier en démocratie la conséquence de tout ça
c'est que dans une élection présidentielle, ce qui m'intéresse moi personnellement le plus
ce n'est pas ce que disent ce que pensent ou quelles sont les personnalités ou les traits physiques ou moraux
des candidats à la présidentielle
ce qui m'intéresse moi le plus
c'est de savoir quels sont les électorats de ces différents candidats
et si possible, mais c'est plus difficile à savoir,
quels sont les lobbys qui les poussent et les aident
à avoir du financement, à faire leur campagne électorale et tout ça.
Enfin, Jérémy Rouxel me demande si à force de voir le monde comme quelque chose de parfaitement mécanique
et tout ça y compris le fonctionnement des individus je ne déprimais pas.
Alors pas du tout.
Moi ça me fait même plaisir de voir que tout peut s'expliquer dans un modèle aussi mécanique.
En fait moi à la base la politique ça ne m'intéresse absolument pas.
Le jour où j'ai commencé à m'intéresser vraiment à la politique
c'est le jour où j'ai découvert que la meilleure façon de décrire et de prédire la politique
c'était de manière totalement mécanique.
Tout à coup plein de choses se sont illuminées dans ma tête
et c'est là que j'ai commencé à trouver la politique intéressante
et en fait toute la politique ne m'intéresse pas
je dirais même qu'il y a beaucoup de choses en politique que je trouve horriblement ennuyeuses
Par contre, cette logique, ce jeu politique qu'il peut y avoir
et la manière dont chaque candidat essaie d'optimiser ses chances d'être et de rester au pouvoir,
ça je trouve ça intéressant.
Alors clairement je suis assez cynique comme personne
et je trouve qu'il y a une certaine beauté dans ce cynisme,
surtout lorsque, à partir de positions très cyniques,
on en arrive quand même à une société qui marche incroyablement bien.
Si on prend le temps de prendre 3 pas de recul et de regarder notre société,
c'est fou à quel point la société va bien.
Notamment lorsqu'on sait que tout le monde économico-politique
est gouverné par ce désir d'être et de rester au pouvoir.
Il y a quelque chose d'assez magique derrière tout ça.
J'espère que vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
il faut savoir que tout a été filmé avant le résultat du premier tour de l'élection présidentielle
donc au moment où je me filme là je ne sais pas du tout ce qui s'est passé.
Et de toute façon la prochaine vidéo a déjà été écrite,
donc elle sera indépendante des résultats du premier tour de l'élection présidentielle.
La prochaine vidéo parlera de ce qui est à mon sens le plus important
en politique en général mais surtout en démocratie en particulier,
qui est le fait que nous nous comportons essentiellement
comme des hooligans politiques.
Si vous avez liké cet épisode pensez à le liker à le commenter à le partager
pensez à vous abonner pour ne pas manquer les futurs épisodes,
Merci aux Tipeurs pour leurs dons
et j'espère que vous serez là la prochaine fois.